[Musik]
ich bin vom ZDF und natürlich zur
Neutralität verpflichtet deswegen die
Frage wer ist an allem Schuld und warum
sind die grün weil sie schuld sind weil
die alles verändern wollen ma doch
nichts sind doch keine Spezialisten sind
doensteiger mit abgebrochenen Studium
haben Kinderbuchautoren die werden
monister Kinderbuchautoren ja ja was
würden Sie machen wenn bei ihm Wahlkampf
wäre und ein grüner wird an der Tür
klingeln ja den l gar nicht re weil s ja
schon wieder
aus ja wie wie schaut aus anders
gekleidet wie sieht aus so so
schlapperig da hab ich nicht der ist
kein Politiker der ist ein Buchautor und
da hätte dabei bleiben sollen und die
lang ist eine Frau die hat nie eine
Stunde gearbeitet pass auf ich bin
Landwirt ja Bauer ja
Landwirtschaftsminister einem ja ein ja
irgen hgund von der Landwirtschaft ist
weil se Großvater
inatolionen gehabt hat das ist der
Hintergrund von der Landwirtschaft wir
haben alle schwimmen gelernt ja was
passiert heute die Jugend SFT ab we SFT
ab weil sie zum Teil nicht mehr
schwimmen lernen können was hat das mit
den Grünen zu tun im Moment nich hier in
Bayern z. was mir aufft es gibt ja
relativ wenig windreder das ist ja auch
so so so grünes Projekt oder so soll es
hier
die Lachen W jetzt hier windeder nach
Bayern ne also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wir haben so viel schwachsinnige
ja dumm studierte ja doof doof junge
Leute in Deutschland nicht alle Gott sei
Dank ja die studieren B 26 28 30 Jahre
ja dreimal ums Eck ja ja und was kommt
am Schluss raus was ein dummer Mensch
ein dummer Mensch und wo geht er hin
er geht in die Politik ja zu den Grünen
ja okay all also oder ja oder er geht
aufs Arbeitsamt könnten Sie was mit
einer veganen Weißwurst anfangen würde
nie probieren haben Sie schon mal jemals
in ihren Leben vegetarisch ein Produkt
gegessen nur Fleisch nur Fleisch und mit
diesen schönen Worten gebe ich zurück
ins Studio das ist was vegan ist oder
das ist vegan W ich nicht anfassen sch
wirterlich
aus
so
Aufnahme hallo dies ist die automatische
endcut von Oliver Welke und der heute
show leider ist das Video schon vorbei
ihr könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen